♪ ♪
>> Laura: THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION'S TRADE
NEGOTIATORS LEFT BEIJING ON
FRIDAY WITH NO SIGN OF A DEAL TO
LEVEL THE PLAYING FIELD.
THAT CAUSED SOME ANALYSTS TO
WORRY THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
APPLICATION OF TARIFFS AND
PUBLIC PRESSURE ON CHINA ISN'T
WORKING.
OTHER ANALYSTS HOWEVER BELIEVING
THAT BEIJING WILL EVENTUALLY
HAVE TO AGREE TO A DEAL BECAUSE
IT'S SO DEPENDENT ON THE
UNITED STATES FOR TRADE.
LET'S GET A READ ON THE
NEGOTIATIONS FROM A NATIONAL
REVIEW COLUMNIST, HANSEN FROM
THE -- NYU PROFESSOR IAN BREMMER
WHO IS THE AUTHOR OF THE GREAT
NEW BOOK US VERSUS THEM.
LET'S START WITH YOU.
COMING UP EMPTY, OR IS THIS JUST
THE NORMAL PROCESS?
WE DIDN'T LOSE GROUND FOR CHINA
OVERNIGHT AND WE WILL NOT HAVE A
DEAL WITH CHINA OVERNIGHT EITHER
DEAL WITH CHINA OVERNIGHT EITHE
EITHER.
>> I THINK IT'S PART OF THE ART
OF THE DEAL NEGOTIATING STYLE OF
TRUMP AND THEN TRUMP, WHEN HE
CAME INTO OFFICE, I THINK
EVERYBODY REALIZED THERE WAS AN
ASYMMETRY WITH CHINA WHETHER IT
WAS INFRINGEMENT OR COPYRIGHT OR
TECHNOLOGY APPROPRIATION FROM
AMERICAN COMPANIES AND DUMPING
AND CYBER WARFARE, ET CETERA,
ET CETERA, AND THAT THEORY THAT
IF WE WORK TO GIVE THESE
CONCESSIONS TO CHINA IN THE
EARLY '80s WE WOULD BRING THEM
INTO THE FAMILY OF NATIONS AND
THEIR AFFLUENCE AND THEIR
ECONOMIC BOOM WOULD MAKE THEM
DEMOCRATIZED AND THEY WOULD BE
SORT OF A HELPFUL PLAYER IN THE
WORLD SCENE, THAT HAS BEEN
REVEALED TO BE FLAWED.
I THINK IT IS SORT OF SCHEMATIC
ABOUT THESE ASYMMETRICAL -- THE
IRAN DEAL, THE OPEN BORDERS, THE
NATO CONTRIBUTIONS THAT WE
THOUGHT WHAT WAS NORMAL REALLY
WASN'T.
IT WAS PREDICATED ON THE IDEA
THAT WE WERE SO STRONG AND
POWERFUL WE COULD ALWAYS MAKE
CONCESSIONS AND THEN IN 2016 THE
PEOPLE IN BETWEEN THE COAST SAID
WE DON'T WANT TO MAKE
CONCESSIONS BECAUSE WE ARE NOT
AS POWERFUL, AT LEAST WE AREN'T.
AND AS AFFLUENT AS YOU PEOPLE
WHO CREATE THESE DEALS.
THERE IS A DOMESTIC, POLITICAL
ELEMENT IN ALL OF THESE
NEGOTIATIONS THAT TRUMP HAS TO
BE CAREFUL OF.
>> Laura: IT IS INTERESTING TO
SEE HOW TRUMP HAS SHIFTED THE
DEBATE ON CHINA.
I WAS GOING BACK JUST GOOGLING
TRUMP WAS RIGHT ON CHINA.
FINANCIAL TIMES -- I'M
PARAPHRASING, MARCO RUBIO'S WAY
OVER, PROBABLY TO THE RIGHT OF
TRUMP ON CHINA AND NOW IT IS
PRETTY MUCH COMMONLY THOUGHT
CHINA IS CHEATING ON A WHOLE
HOST OF ISSUES, THEY ARE
STEALING A LOT OF OUR
INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY AND THEY
ARE POISED TO ECLIPSE THE
UNITED STATES IN A LOT OF
DIFFERENT WAYS UNLESS WE
RECALIBRATE AT LEAST THE PLAYING
FIELD.
WHERE DO THINGS STAND NOW, AND
THEN WE WILL MOVE TO THE IRAN
DEAL VERY QUICK.
>> THEY ARE MARKUP POWERFUL.
THEY ARE A LARGER ECONOMY.
THEIR ABILITY TO PROMOTE THEIR
OWN COMPANIES BECAUSE THEY ARE
NOT BECOMING A FREE MARKET
ECONOMY IS MAKING IT MUCH HARDER
FOR THE AMERICANS TO HAVE
ACCESS.
TRUMP HAS BEEN HITTING THEM
PARTICULARLY HARD ON THE
TECHNOLOGY SIDE AND THAT'S WHERE
FRANKLY WE DON'T HAVE A LOT OF
INTERDEPENDENCE.
THAT'S WHERE I THINK THE
RELATIONSHIP IS GOING TO BE MORE
CHALLENGING.
ON TRADE, THEY WANT TO EXPORT TO
US, WE WANT TO IMPORT FROM THEM
AND A LOT OF OUR COMPANIES THAT
ARE ACTUALLY MANUFACTURING AND
EXPORTING, I DON'T THINK THE
HEADLINE IS GOING TO LEAD TO A
TRADE WAR.
I THINK BOTH SIDES WILL ACTUALLY
END UP NEGOTIATING.
>> Laura: LET'S GO TO YOU ON
THE ISSUE OF THE IRAN DEAL.
THE BIG ISSUE TOMORROW.
HERE'S THE HEADLINE FROM THE
TELEGRAPH TONIGHT.
IF TRUMP SCRAPS THE IRAN NUCLEAR
AGREEMENT, WHY SHOULD
NORTH KOREA MAKE ITS OWN DEAL
WITH AMERICA?
THAT'S THE CONVENTIONAL WISDOM,
IT'S GOING TO BE BAD FOR
NORTH KOREA, I THINK YOU CAN
MAKE THE OTHER ARGUMENT.
YOU CAN SAY ACTUALLY SHOWS THAT
TRUMP WILL NOT SIGN ON TO A DEAL
THAT HE VIEWS IS NOT IN OUR
INTEREST OR THE INTEREST OF OUR
MIDDLE EASTERN ALLIES.
YOUR REACTION TO THIS POTENTIAL
MOVE?
>> I AGREE WITH THE LATTER
INTERPRETATION, THAT NORTH KOREA
WILL GET A MESSAGE THAT IF IT'S
NOT SYMMETRICAL IT'S NOT GOING
TO STAND THE TEST OF TIME, BUT
MORE IMPORTANTLY, WE SHOULDN'T
EVEN BE HERE BECAUSE THAT SHOULD
HAVE BEEN A TREATY AND OBAMA DID
NOT HAVE THE VOTES IN THE
CONGRESS, THE SENATE AND SO HE
WENT AROUND THEM AND THE SAD
THING ABOUT IT -- THEY WERE
BLEEDING ABOUT 125, ABOUT
150 BILLION A YEAR.
I GIVE THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
CREDIT FOR FINALLY RATCHETING UP
THE SANCTIONS.
OVER THE LIKES OF THE FIRST TEN
AND THE ADDITIONAL FIVE YEARS
THEY WILL HAVE ABOUT A HALF A
TRILLION TO 700 BILLION THAT
THEY OTHERWISE WOULDN'T HAVE HAD
AND WE CAN SEE WHERE THAT IS
GOING.
IT'S GOING TO SHOOT MISSILES
INTO SAUDI ARABIA.
IT'S GOING FOR HAS BLAH IT
WASN'T MORE THAN SIX MONTHS
AFTER THIS TREATY AND THEY WERE
SHOOTING A MISSILE AT THE
USS TRUMAN.
THEY HIJACKED -- IT DIDN'T HAVE
THE ADDED EFFECT OF AFFECTING
THEIR MISSILE PROGRAM OR THEIR
BEHAVIOR AND I DON'T THINK THEY
WERE GOING TO BE ABLE TO PRODUCE
ANY NUCLEAR WEAPONS IN THAT
TENURE.
NOT BECAUSE THEY HAD CIVIL
UNREST AND THEIR ECONOMY WAS
RUINED.
NOW THEY'VE GOT A GREEN LIGHT IN
TEN YEARS AND I THINK THEY WILL
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF IT.
>> Laura: WHERE DOES THIS
STAND TONIGHT?
>> TWO THINGS I WOULD SAY.
THE FIRST IS THAT WE KNOW ALL OF
AMERICA'S ALLIES IN EUROPE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE
UNITED STATES LEADING BY
OURSELVES.
THE FRENCH AND THE GERMAN
LEADERS WERE HERE ASKING TRUMP
TO GIVE THEM SOME TIME SO THAT
THEY COULD TRY TO COME UP WITH
WHAT WOULD BE A TOUGHER DEAL
AGAINST THE IRANIANS.
IF I WAS ADVISING TRUMP RIGHT
NOW I WOULD SAY MAY 12TH IS YOUR
DEADLINE, GIVE THEM TWO MORE
MONTHS AND IF IT TURNS OUT THEY
DON'T COME UP WITH ANYTHING
ELSE, YOU SAY IT'S THEIR FAULT.
YOU LISTEN TO THE ALICE, YOU
HAVE THE ABILITY TO BLAME THEM.
IF THEY GIVE YOU SOMETHING
BETTER THAN YOU ARE A HERO AND
YOU'VE ALSO GOT BETTER
CREDIBILITY ON IRAN.
ONE OTHER POINT, TRUMP NEVER
BRINGS UP THE FACT THAT THE ONE
THING AMERICANS CARE ABOUT IS
NOT THE MIDDLE EAST BUT THEY
WANT OIL PRICES DOWN.
THIS DEAL IS ACTUALLY KEEPING